AGUSTIN FONTS: Good
morning, everybody.
My name is Agustin
Fonts, and I am
a product manager on the
Android UI Framework Team.
And if you're wondering, I do
work on Android text and fonts.
And, yes, Fonts is
my real last name.
So, with that out of
the way, let's begin.
So today we want to
cover a few things.
First we want to
convey how we think
about APK size in
a couple of metrics
that we think you
really should care
about for the
success of your app.
We'll also walk through a
series of best practices
that are going to help you
reduce your APK size today,
as well as show you a number
of new tools and features
that we are going to introduce
this week that will also help
you keep your APK size down.
So let's get started.
One of the things
you'll see today
is that we have a really diverse
group of people from Google--
people from the Android
team, from the tools team,
from the Play team, internal
developers at Google.
And the reason we
have so many people
on stage with
different backgrounds
is because we really think that
APK size is super important.
And it's something that
we see as something you
have to take care of from the
design stage, the time you
build your app, the time
you publish your app,
and the time that that app
gets delivered to a device.
So let me tell you a
little bit about kind
of the two dimensions
that we think
are important for APK size.
First is the download size.
So this is the size
of the application
when it's in the
Play Store and it
gets delivered to the device.
This is highly compressed-- and
we'll tell you more about how
we do that--
and that allows us to save
a lot of size on the wire
and in user's data.
Now, as we said, download
size is pretty small,
but there's another
concept that's important,
which is installed size.
So installed size is what
happens when you actually
download the app, unpack
it, and then compile it
and optimize it, which expands
the application significantly,
yielding a download size that
is sometimes two to three times
even bigger than
the download size.
And so it's something
to really think about,
is what is the footprint
of your application
going to be once it's
installed on the device?
Now let's talk a
little bit about why
you should care about both
download size and installed
size.
On the download size front, this
is something really important,
because what happens is when a
user goes and installs an app,
they're going to
see that loading bar
and they're going to see the
actual size of the application.
And what we see is
the larger the app,
the more sort of user
regret that happens.
And a lot of people will go
and actually back out of it
and cancel.
And so what we see is that up
to 20% of downloads fail or get
canceled, rather,
when applications
are over a hundred megabytes.
And so you really want
to keep that download
size small to
ensure that you get
as much distribution for
your app as possible.
The other one to think
about is installed size.
Now installed size has a sort
of a similar phenomenon, right?
So users are going to be filling
up their phones with photos,
videos, and more applications.
And at some point, they're going
to try to install a new app,
and they're going
to realize that they
don't have space for it.
What's going to
happen at that point
is they're going to go hunting.
They're going to go
to their settings.
They're going to look
through their apps.
Or if their disk
is full and they
try to download an app
from the Play Store,
even the Play Store
will suggest that they
remove some applications,
and they give them
a list of suggestions.
What we see here is that, again,
apps that are pretty large,
especially a hundred
megabytes or above,
are eight times more likely
to be removed from the device.
So this is really going
to hurt your re-engagement
if your app is more
likely to get uninstalled.
So I hope that I've given you
a little bit of motivation
to think twice, maybe three
times, about your APK size.
Go back and think
about what you can do.
And what we want to show you
today is a number of ways
you can follow to
reduce that APK size.
Some are going to be
existing practices that
have been out there
for a while, and we're
going to hope to
summarize and make
them really compact for you.
And others are new, and we're
going to show you those.
So let's roll up our sleeves.
We're going to be working
with the Topeka app.
You may have seen it in our
code labs or sample apps.
Topeka is a quiz
app, so it has a lot
of resources, a lot of assets.
It also has a good
chunk of dex code.
This is what gets compiled
and expanded on devices.
It's definitely a good
opportunity to tackle dex code
and make it smaller due
to its outsize impact.
In a typical production
app, you might also
see some shared objects.
This doesn't happen
in Topeka, but we'll
cover a little bit
also what you can
do with your shared objects.
So at this point, I'd
like to hand it over
to Shai, who's going to run
through a lot of these concepts
and best practices in real time.
So hopefully you see that
it's not too difficult,
and it's something you
can do with your app.
SHAI BARACK: Thanks, Mr. Fonts.
So here we have our
app built and running.
I can press Build
APK to get an APK,
and then press Analyze
APK to crack it open
and see what it's made of.
I already have it open here.
So an APK is just a
glorified zip file.
Here we can see all
of its contents.
We can browse through
the resources folder
to see all of the large
drawables that really dominate
the most bytes in our app.
We can look at classes.dex--
that stands for Dalvik
Executable--
and see all the
code for our app,
as well as of some
of our dependencies.
We can even look
inside resources.arsc
and see, for instance, all the
translatable strings and styles
and dimensions and
other resources that
end up in the resources.arsc.
We can even look at the
AndroidManifest binary XML
and decode that.
Notice that there are two
columns with size information.
First we have raw file size.
This is how much
every particular item
contributes to the size of
the APK as a file on disk.
The second is download size,
which better represents
how much bytes the
user will actually
have to download from
Play in order to install
your app for the first time.
Now you'll see, for
instance, that for resources
these numbers aren't
very far apart,
because resources are
dominated by large PNGs
we have for drawables.
These don't benefit from
further compression.
Whereas for some other items,
entropy is typically lower,
and so the gains from
compression are higher.
We're going to show
you a bunch of tricks
you can use for this
particular app, which we're
going to use right now
on stage, and we're
going to show you their
impact on the app size.
For your own app,
your mileage may vary.
Rather than memorizing
these particular steps,
if there's one lesson
that you should take home
from this talk, it's that
optimizing your own app size
begins with sort of
finding out what's in it
and tailoring to that.
All right?
So first step we're going
to take is to use ProGuard.
ProGuard is enabled by
default for release builds,
and it's a whole
program Java optimizer.
What it does is
basically three things.
So one thing it does is
it optimizes your code
in ways that don't
change the functionality
but do change the representation
to make it more compact.
For instance, it might
inline certain methods
to their call sites if it's
deemed to be more efficient.
In some cases, it is.
Another thing it
does is it obfuscates
names of types and
methods and fields,
where the original name doesn't
matter so that long names are
replaced with short strings
like a and b for efficiency.
I know we all like
to give our Java
classes long names
in our packages,
but they shouldn't get
in the way of efficiency.
And then lastly, there's
dead code elimination.
Now, this is the most
important role of ProGuard,
so pay attention.
Think of your program as a graph
of classes, methods, and fields
as nodes, and calls or
references as edges.
So Android apps have
well known entry points
at activities, services,
broadcast receivers,
content providers,
and optionally
a custom application class.
If these classes are
in your app manifest,
then the platform
can call into them.
So ProGuard marks them
as live because this code
can execute at run time, right?
ProGuard then
propagates liveness
across the program
via references.
So it's basically a tree
exploration sort of algorithm,
and anything that is
reachable from those seeds
is considered live.
Then whatever code remains,
the complement to that
is presumed dead and will
be deleted from your app
unless you specify otherwise.
This is important
to be aware of.
So let's look at
the impact of that.
Here's what happens when
we run ProGuard on Topeka.
You'll see that most of the
code is now completely gone.
So, for instance, if I look
at the support library here,
I see that it's considerably
smaller than it was before.
We can also get these results
using the APK analyzer.
We can compare one
APK with another.
Here we have numbers
in raw APK size.
And over in the
charts on the slides
I have it as download size.
Thought you'd appreciate that.
So if we look closely
inside a dex file,
you'll see what I
just showed you,
that most of the support
library code is gone,
and most of the rest
is obfuscated, right?
So what is going on?
Why is this happening?
There we go.
ProGuard allows
you to choose what
libraries you want to use
without having to worry so
much about all this stuff in the
libraries that you don't need,
and how it might
bloat your app size.
In this case, we're using the
support library, v4 and v7,
and notifications and design,
and all kinds of assets.
And we're only using a subset
of the support library,
so everything we're
not using just
gets torn away at build
time and eliminated.
Now some of you might be
thinking, this is nice.
It's a nice benefit,
but the optimizations
make debugging more
difficult. So hold
that thought until
the next demo.
What we've done for code, we
can do for resources as well.
Same principle here.
Resource shrinking extends the
concept of ProGuard's dead code
elimination to resources.
So in this example,
drawables whose references
are reachable from live
code are kept in your APK,
and then everything
else is deleted.
Now our app is
almost 4x smaller,
and this is no mistake.
All we've done is tweak
two lines of Gradle,
but what we get is,
once again, things
that go into sort of
the transitive closure
of dependencies of
our app but are not
actually useful to the app.
So once again, this
is due to features
included in our dependencies
that we don't need.
The support libraries in this
case contain a lot of design
assets that you could
use, but Topeka isn't.
So we can just make all
the dead weight go away.
But we can do even better.
So if you recall, we saw that
in the resource folder when
we were looking with
the APK analyzer,
we have drawables for
different screen densities.
What's going on?
The Android ecosystem
is diverse with support
for different displays
and different CPU
types and other such things.
By default, when you build
an APK with all the material
to service as many
devices as possible,
we call that the Universal APK.
You get a larger APK than
what's actually needed
on each particular device.
Every specific device
that runs your app
will only use files for
its particular density.
And if you have
native code, then
for its particular
CPU architecture
and other such things
that APKs can vary on.
Fortunately, you can split your
build across these dimensions,
and then upload multiple APKs
to Play, each one tailored
to a particular device type.
Here we intentionally look
at the APK build for xxhdpi
density screens, which contains
the largest PNGs, because this
is the largest APK
that we're building
for this app in this example.
You will see that the difference
is significant even when
comparing the Universal APK to
the largest split that we have.
And, of course,
the difference is
more pronounced for
hdpi and dpi, et cetera.
Speaking of PNGs
and densities, we
can do even better
with vector drawables.
Tell them, Gus.
AGUSTIN FONTS: Thanks, Shai.
So now we just saw
that there's a way
to deliver a smaller app by
chunking it up and delivering
multiple of those apps.
Now that's a great
benefit to APK size,
but it does come at a cost for
your build process, as well
as your QA process, and that
might be something that you're
not quite ready to get into.
So there's an
additional approach
you can follow to reduce
the amount of size
you carry with your assets, and
that's to use vector drawables.
Vector drawables
would-- basically
it's serving a vector
into your application.
So there's a single
asset that can serve up
all of the densities.
For this particular
asset on screen,
the vector drawable
is actually smaller
than the smallest density
PNG, so it's quite nice.
And this is, I would
consider it to be
kind of a medium complexity
vector with somewhat
complex paths, but not
necessarily gradients
and things like that.
The thing that makes, I
think, vector drawable very
usable and exciting today is
that in Support Library 23.2,
we introduced support
for vector drawables
backwards compatible
all the way to API 14.
Also, within, we
introduced gradient support
of vector drawable,
so hopefully that
gives you kind of a
wider range of things
you can do with vectors.
Now one thing to keep
in mind with vectors
is that they can increase
your RAM and CPU load,
especially when you first
start up the application.
So if you have an app that is--
sorry, a series of assets
that are pretty complex,
then you probably want to do
kind of a bit of a performance
test and make sure
that you're not
sacrificing a lot of performance
in exchange for a smaller app
size.
Now let's look at the savings.
After substituting
most of the PNGs
with vector assets,
which this app is
very good at because it's all
flat images with relatively
low complexity, we see
that vector drawables
is a little bit
better than multi-APK.
That kind of makes sense,
right, because we're
carrying just a single
asset in the application.
Our advice would be
that you consider
what kind of image assets
are in your application.
So if they are relatively
simple and flat,
you should definitely
consider it.
And then that also
simplifies your build and QA
process so that you only have
to produce one APK to upload
to Play.
So let me hand it back to Shai
for one more best practice.
SHAI BARACK: Awesome.
Thanks.
So finally, we're going
to see a specialized
trick for resources.arsc.
That's Topeka's ARSC file.
So Topeka's ARSC file,
as we saw, is small,
but we'll make it 2x smaller
with one line, because we can.
So here you can look
inside the ARSC file
and view all the
strings translation,
and also here live on stage.
Now you'll notice that some
strings only appear in English.
For instance, there's going to
be sign in here and sign out,
but other strings have as many
as 82 translations for them.
Why is this happening?
So the Support Library
folks went out of their way
to localize your strings.
And kudos to them because
this is the right thing
for a library to do.
A lot of apps go
to similar lengths
to translate their own strings,
and you want the libraries
to kind of line up so
that the app isn't half
translated, right?
Not the case with Topeka.
It didn't bother with
anything but English, which
is typical of our sample apps.
Translating your app is a good
way to reach out to more users,
and we absolutely
encourage that.
Google translates
all of its apps
to as many languages as this,
but a half-translated app
can make a poor user experience.
And then what's worse is
these empty spaces actually
use up bytes in our ARSC
file by indicating no entries
across 82 locales
for all the strings
that weren't translated.
So what are we going to do?
We're going to get rid of them.
And we can fix all of this by
simply stating that we only
want to retain English
strings, and then all
the half translations
just disappear right out.
So I know this is hard
to see the difference,
but if you look
under your seats,
you will find a pair
of binoculars each.
Made you look.
As promised, ARSC
is now 2x smaller.
Although, in the big picture,
this doesn't do much since
it was small to begin with.
On the other hand, I've seen
real apps that are 40% ARSC.
True story.
So once again, your
mileage may vary.
Now let's take a look back
and appreciate the fact
that our Topeka app is
now 5x smaller than when
we started-- over 5x, in fact--
and it's not even 10:00 AM.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
What I've shown you so far is
all existing functionality.
Now I'll hand it over
to Clara to tell us
about some new stuff.
CLARA BAYARRI: Thank you, Shai.
SHAI BARACK: New stuff, Clara.
CLARA BAYARRI: Hi,
I'm Clara Bayarri.
I'm a tech lead on the
Android UI Toolkit Team,
and I work on fonts.
So here I'm very excited
to introduce, today we're
presenting downloadable fonts.
Fonts are a source of bloat
for apps, and we know that.
They're heavy files.
They're stuck into your
app, and you need them
because you need it for your UX.
That's fine.
We figured out that,
actually, most fonts
that you are
bundling in your apps
are not even
optimized for mobile.
So about half of the file
size that you're adding
is not even something we're
going to use in Android.
So that's a shame.
Also, we looked
at the Play Store,
and we figured out that the top
25 apps that bundle fonts are
actually bundling
about an average of 500
kilobytes in fonts that we own
in the Google Fonts catalog.
We're like, OK, we should be
able to do something with that,
right?
Never mind the fact
that several apps
are bundling the same fonts,
and you're duplicating them
in your device.
So that's where
downloadable fonts comes in.
You've typically bundled
fonts in your app,
and that causes your
APK size to increase.
With downloadable fonts,
we're introducing the concept
of a fonts provider.
There you go.
Ah.
Can we go back, please?
There you go.
Fonts provider is a separate
app that is not yours that is--
its own mission is to
fetch fonts for you,
cache them, and serve them
to you when you need them.
This means that you can stop
bundling fonts in your app
and trust the font
provider to do it for you.
The way this works
is all apps can just
contact the font provider
via the font's contract APIs.
These are available
in Android O,
and in Support
Library 26-beta 1.
By doing this, all of the apps
are contacting the same font
provider, which means we
have one copy of the font
that all apps are
using at the same time.
What does this mean really?
Well, it means we save
memory, because we're only
loading the font
once and sharing
that memory between all apps.
We're also saving APK
size for all of these apps
because they don't have
to bundle the font.
We just have one copy.
We're obviously saving
disk space for the user
because all of your
apps are smaller.
And we're also saving network if
you are actually fetching fonts
from the network, as only
the font provider is the one
responsible for pitching these.
This is available in
Support Library today.
And I'm very proud to announce
our very first font provider,
which is available.
It's a great collaboration
we've done with the Google Fonts
Team, where we're providing the
entire Google Fonts catalog--
and that is 800 fonts--
available to your app to
use free from APK size.
Isn't that amazing?
That is done through
Google Play services.
It has a tiny caveat.
This is in Google
Play Services v11,
which is currently in beta.
Next I want to hand
it over to Wojtek
to give you a very
smooth demo of how
Android Studio has integrated
with downloadable fonts.
WOJTEK KALICINSKI:
Thank you, Clara.
[APPLAUSE]
So hi, everyone.
My name is Wojtek.
I'm a developer advocate working
closely with the Android Studio
Team, and today I
want to walk you
through some of the new features
we have in Android Studio
and Tools that are
relevant to APK size
and hopefully will let you
keep your APK size down.
So as Clara explained,
downloadable fonts
are a great way to make your
apps look pretty without adding
the bloat to your APK.
So let me show you how easy
we can add downloadable fonts
to your apps in Android Studio.
So here I have open
one of the layout files
from the Topeka app.
And you can see if I
click on the Text View
here on the right in
the layout inspector,
I can actually go
and change the fonts.
So I scroll down.
And if I select More Fonts--
there's this new picker
in Android Studio 3.0
that we just
announced yesterday--
and you can see
here, you have access
to literally hundreds of fonts
from the Google Fonts catalog.
And if I could just
choose one, here I
can select the
downloadable font.
I can see the font immediately
change in the preview.
But then, what's
more, Android Studio
also includes support
for binary and XML fonts
project structure, and see
your preview or edit it.
So that's one thing.
But when we're on the
topic of resources,
we are also making changes
to AAPT, which is the Android
Asset Packaging Tool.
This is the part
of the build system
that processes and packages all
your resources into the APK.
And with Android Studio 3.0, we
are introducing a new version
of AAPT, AAPT 2, which has a
few neat tricks for reducing
your APK size.
So first up, we have something
we call version collapsing.
So normally, when
you develop an app,
you add resources for
various versions of Android.
Typically, you want to
have different colors
or different styles for
the different versions
of the platform.
And that also
happens, for example,
in the Support Library,
which you normally
bring into your apps.
But as you develop your
app, and time passes,
you normally start raising
your min SDK version and kind
of restricting the versions of
Android that your apps run on.
But these resources
still remain,
especially if they come
from external dependencies,
so they take up unnecessary
space in your APK.
So with AAPT 2, we are
introducing version collapsing,
where AAPT2 can actually figure
out the min SDK of your app
and get rid of all these
resources that are unneeded.
And what's more, it can
collapse the configurations
in your app to reduce
the size of the resources
file even further,
only including
the resources that you
actually will need.
Next up, we have
resource deduplication.
So another example.
Here I'm showing different
translations for your app.
And it happens sometimes
that for some languages
for some configurations,
like here--
French and French Canadian--
mostly the translations
will be the same.
Most of the words
are exactly the same,
except for just a few.
And it doesn't make
sense to actually keep
these duplicate resources
in the resources file.
So what AAPT2 will
do now is it will
find those duplicate
resources, get rid of them,
and let the system default
to the default configuration.
So this is version collapsing
and resource deduplication.
AAPT2 does a couple of
more internal things.
Like, it starts
using UTF-8 for text,
for string resources
included in XML files,
like layouts and the
binary resources file.
It has a smarter cruncher.
This is the part that reduces
the size of your images
by optimizing them.
And if it finds that
your images are actually
already pre-optimized and
the output of AAPT2 crunching
would be bigger, then it just
discards those bigger versions
and uses smaller ones.
So we aim to enable AAPT2 as the
default in Android Studio 3.0
stable.
However, you can try it now
with the [INAUDIBLE] release.
All you have to do
is add this one line
to your Gradle properties file.
So I encourage you
to try it, and reduce
the size of your APKs
without doing anything.
So, like I said, you don't have
to change a single line of code
when you use AAPT2, but
sometimes that's not enough.
Sometimes you actually want
to go in, and in fact--
and change things
in your app, and you
need tools to help
you make decisions
of where to actually go and
make those optimizations.
So, like Shai mentioned before,
one of the biggest changes
you can make to your
app to reduce APK size
is enable ProGuard to shrink
away code and resources.
But when talking to developers
at conferences like this,
I often hear that it's
very difficult to debug
build problems and
run time problems that
can stem from enabling
ProGuard in your apps.
And developers
were really lacking
tools that will let them inspect
those problems in detail.
That's why we were making
some improvements to the APK
analyzer in Android Studio.
Let me show you on an example.
Can we switch to
the demo, please?
So here I have Android
Studio 3.0 kind
of running on my machine.
And one of the first things--
sorry, I'm going to walk
you through a few things
that we're adding to let you
better debug program problems,
but we've also
added some UI tweaks
to the APK analyzer
that hopefully will make
working with it even easier.
So the first thing
you might notice
is we now have multidex support.
So I can select
multiple dex files
and actually see
a combined preview
of all the code in my app.
So this is a very
simple example.
This is not the Topeka app.
This is just an APK I created
for the purpose of this demo.
And you can see,
I can drill down
to the source code of my app
here and actually see all
the other classes that I have.
And the app really
has two parts.
It's very simple.
It just has an activity
and it has a fragment.
The thing is, the fragment,
the way I use it is I only
use it from a layout XML file.
And that will be
important later.
We've also made some other
tweaks to the dex viewer.
So, for example, we have
some filtering options,
and I can, for example,
disable showing classes.
They're a reference from my
file but are not actually
defined in it.
But moving onto ProGuard.
So this is a debug build.
For this, ProGuard
is not enabled.
So I built my release APK.
I run it.
And the first big problem
with the app is it crashes.
It crashes on startup.
I don't know why.
It failed the class
not found exception.
And the second problem is,
if I actually go and try
to debug the problem,
I can see, again,
like Shai mentioned, that
all the names of my types,
of my fields, methods,
they were all changed
to strings like a, b, c.
It's very difficult to
debug the problem here.
So what I can do now with
the new Android Studio
is I can actually load
the program mappings that
were created when
my APK was built.
So let me open the program
mapping folder here.
And now you can see
the dex viewer changed.
First, I can actually see all
the names of classes, packages.
Everything's back like it was
in my original source code.
Second, I can actually
go here and see now
that my blank
fragment is missing.
That's because ProGuard was not
able to automatically detect
the text that is
being used in my code.
What's more, I can
press this button here,
which will let me show
all the removed nodes that
were removed by ProGuard.
[APPLAUSE]
Yep.
So I found the
blank fragment here.
It was removed.
I right-click on it, and I can
actually generate a ProGuard
rule that I can--
[APPLAUSE]
--that I can simply
copy and paste
to my ProGuard configuration.
So I'm going to
choose the first rule.
It's the simplest one.
I just want to keep the
class and all its members.
So I copy it here.
I rebuild my app.
And I open the APK
after rebuilding it.
I've loaded the
program mappings so
that we can keep things brief.
I open it.
And what's more, I can see that
the blank fragment is not only
here, it's shown in bold, which
means it was explicitly kept
by the ProGuard configuration.
So that's the ProGuard
support in Android Studio
in APK analyzer.
But there's more.
For real power users, you can
actually now go and figure out
how the classes that you use and
the dependencies that you have
pull even more code
inside your app.
So for example, I know
that in my source code
I'm using this class
called Optional,
but I've never used
this one or this one.
So why is it here?
I can now right-click
on any class or method,
and actually find usages and
get a nice tree of dependencies
and see that actually
this Present class is
used by this method
from the Optional, which
I'm using from my onCreate.
What's more, I can
actually verify that
by opening my onCreate
method, and looking
at the exact bytecode
of that method.
Now I know not every one of
you will need to use this,
but if you work with
very complicated
build system, if you do your
own bytecode transformations,
now you can actually
analyze the bytecode
that gets packaged in your APK.
OK.
Can we switch back
the slides please?
So this is available
in Android Studio now.
However, there are some more
things that we're working on,
and hopefully you'll get to
play with them in the future,
but now let me give
you a sneak peek.
So in the dex viewer--
previously, we had
only two columns
showing the number of
defined methods and reference
methods, which is useful if
you're debugging problems
with multidex.
Not really problems
with multidex,
but problems with the
number of methods.
We are adding a
third column that
will show you the actual
byte size per package, class,
and even method so you can see
how the functionality you add
to your code, or the libraries
that you pull into your code
base, impact the dex size
and APK size of your app.
And, the last thing
is, Shai showed you
how you can compare
two APKs, but so far
the functionality was quite
limited and only worked
on the raw APK size.
We're expanding the
compare APK action
to give you the actual update
size as delivered by the Play
Store from one version
of your app to the other.
And we even include the
new file-by-file support
that's been added to Play.
And if you're not familiar
with file-by-file patches,
let me invite on stage
James from the Play
Team who can explain it better.
[APPLAUSE]
JAMES SMITH: Thanks.
Hi, everyone.
My name is James.
I'm a product manager on
the Google Play Store.
Play delivers a lot of apps.
In the last year, we delivered
82 billion app installs,
and even more patches to
keep those apps up to date.
We saw earlier in
the presentation
how app size directly
correlates with install success,
so users couldn't be giving
us a more clear signal
that they care about the
size of these downloads.
So in the last year,
Play invested a lot
in taking significant steps to
reduce APK size for downloads
and updates.
I'm delighted to say that
we had some great success,
and I'd like to tell you about
two of those in particular.
The first was
Brotli compression.
Now, at Google, we're always
super proud of our interns,
but this one's going
to take some beating.
Our intern, Anna, took Brotli,
which is a new compression
format from the Google
Research Europe Team,
and applied it to
the Play Store.
That one change reduced our data
usage by 1.5 petabytes a day,
compared to our previous method
of using gzip for everything.
This is crazy, right?
We're super pleased
with these results.
And you can be sure we made Anna
an offer to join us full-time.
[APPLAUSE]
Secondly, when Google
Play updates an app,
as the guys said previously,
we deliver patches.
So we started out by just
delivering the full APK
for each update,
and then we switched
to using diffing algorithms
to generate deltas
between old APKs and new APKs.
Now, there's an issue with this.
As we know, APKs are zip
archives that are compressed.
So take a look at
this blob of text.
On the next slide, I
changed one character.
Did you see it?
It's in the top
left, second word.
Can we go back a slide?
And then we see it again.
OK?
Got it?
Now let's look at the gzip minus
6 compressed version of that.
Here's the first blob of text.
And here's the
second blob of text.
And, remember, we only
changed one character.
So let's see that again?
It's pretty crazy.
So a compressed version produces
a massively different blob
of compressed text.
That means the patch between
the two is very inefficient.
So we decided to get smarter
about how we generate patches.
We launched the new system
called file-by-file patching.
We decided to
uncompress the APKs
and generate the deltas on
the uncompressed versions,
every single file, file by file.
This creates a far
more efficient patch.
And then we reverse
the process when we
apply the patch on the device.
The result?
We saved six petabytes
of user data per day.
On average, patches
are now 65% smaller
than the original app size,
and some are even smaller.
Netflix's original
app is 16 megabytes,
but the patch size was only
one megabyte-- a 92% saving.
So with these two changes,
we've dropped our data usage
by 7.5 petabytes per day.
To put that in
context, that's roughly
equivalent to a hundred years
of HDTV video every single day.
If that doesn't give you an
idea of the scale of Android
in Play--
[APPLAUSE]
[INAUDIBLE]
So next, we're going to
take a different route.
We're introducing
Google Play App Signing.
If you join this
program, Google Play
will manage your
key on your behalf
and sign your app before
delivering it to users.
Now, once Google
Play signs your app,
we can go one step
further, and we can
provide app size optimizations.
Now you heard earlier about
multi-APK and the stuff that's
not required in each device.
If I have a 32-bit
architecture and a hdpi screen,
then I only need the contents
of the boxes in blue,
and the rest of the
APK is completely
unnecessary for my device.
With app optimizations, we
deliver just the right content
for each device.
So if multi-APK is too
difficult or too complicated,
or you're doing it just knowing
you don't want to anymore,
sign up for app optimizations,
and you never need to again.
[APPLAUSE]
You give us a Universal APK,
and we will automatically
create an optimized APK
for different devices
on screen density and
native architecture.
Now, we're just getting
started exploring this area.
It's really early.
But we've tried this
out with a few apps that
were in our Early Access
program for App Signing,
and we expect the average
savings to be about 15%.
However, some apps see
even better results.
Deliveroo was 33% smaller
after the optimizations,
and the 7 Minute Workout app
was nearly a half smaller.
So we're really
excited about this.
We think this is going to
be a huge benefit to users
and developers.
So how can you get
these benefits?
Well, App Signing
is available today.
You can go out and get
enrolled straight away.
We are trialing app
optimizations in beta
with a few select
partners at the moment,
and we hope to widen the
beta in the near future.
So if you're interested
in optimizations,
please enroll in App Signing.
And if you'd like to find
out more about these two,
please come to our talk at 2:30
PM today on Stage 1 next door.
So thank you very
much for listening.
Today we've covered a
lot of the best practices
that you can do to slim
down your APK size.
It's really important
to users, so I really
hope that you take
something away from this
and go and invest in
making this better.
If you'd like to
find out more, you
can talk to the Android and Play
teams in Sandbox Dome C. Thanks
again.
[APPLAUSE]